yeah just a quick reaction to the  russian air strikes reportedly  striking a children's hospital in the  ukrainian city of marriott  i i we have certainly seen those reports  um and as a mother i know a number of  you are mothers yourself it is  horrifying to see the type of  the barbaric use of military  force  to go after innocent civilians in a  sovereign country  and you know i know we've seen the  reports on all that you have all been  broadcasting over the last couple of  hours  unfortunately i don't have more details  than that at this point in time  so far  who has verified 18 attacks on health  facilities health workers and ambulances  including  10 days and 16 injuries  these attacks deprive whole communities  of health care  more than 2 million people have left  ukraine  and who is supporting neighboring  countries to provide health care for  refugees most of whom are  women and children